you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess comm
right now and I just got done going
through several tactics trainer puzzles
and I'd like to share just two of them
with you this time around if you get
them both you're a genius I'm
exaggerating I think you'll feel good
though if you get them both I think
they're tricky let's see what you think
treat this as a pop quiz if you'd like
this first one it's white to move if
you'd like to pause the video what is
the best continuation
okay the answer to this first one is to
grab the bishop allow the fork what is
the way out of the fork Queen f3 this is
the key idea to observe two unprotected
pieces the knight in the Queen the
knight directly the Queen indirectly
this prevents Knight takes rook because
what would follow Knight f6 that's a
check and there goes the Queen that's a
clever way out of a fork to observe the
knight and the Queen and yeah we have
this discovered attack idea up our
sleeve taking advantage of the
unprotected pieces okay let's see this
last one puzzle to like to move what is
the best continuation feel free to pause
the video work it out okay
the solution to this one well before I
share the solution let me share just a
few of the variations I considered feel
free to let me know if you went through
these if you had similar thoughts to
this puzzle it's interesting to read you
know the kind of thoughts we have the
different approaches we have in trying
to work out some puzzles here's one of
the thoughts I had and that was to
interfere with rook takes Queen let me
first point out the queen is under fire
and so too is the knight these are the
two things that should really be
capturing your attention is white
white is just up a pond right now and
runs the risk of dropping a minor piece
if not careful if you're not accurate
here so how do you deal with the the
threat rook takes Queen and the capture
of the knight on c4 this is the big
question
Knight d6 therefore was one of the
thoughts I had but after takes takes
Queen d7 there just is not a good follow
up so much for that
I quickly discounted this move because
both the rook and the bishop are there
and then one last variation I considered
was capturing the knight well this isn't
working because in the end black has a
rook for the minor piece locks up the
exchange so that's not working the key
move here the way out of losing material
is to play Queen to f3 now what is this
move doing this is preparing an attack
against f7 should black capture on c4
with the bishop black can take once on
c4 but should not take twice on Bishop
takes Bishop this will run into a very
cool move in that of e6000 preventing
the bishop from defending f7 and
directly if the black Queen moves to
let's say b6 this is already
checkmate in three and you would even
get to pick your favorite way to deliver
that final checkmating move
so this was the way out this isn't this
wasn't a puzzle to win material but
rather how to prevent the loss of
material seeing that the queen and the
knight are under fire I thought this was
a pretty clever quiet move Queen to f3
preparing that little discovered attack
which is doing a whole lot to crunch the
black position here did I really just
say that I guess I did no worry I won't
use that term too much more but anyhow I
thought these two I thought these two
puzzles were pretty clever feel free to
share how you did with them in the
comment section below and I will catch
you in the next video that's all for now
take care bye
you